Ah, the Quarter-Season Carnival
My favorite time of year
But what about the playoffs?
Oh Kareem, as a game manager on the Chiefs
I've learned to appreciate the little things
like a long incremental drive that ends in a field goal
or being at the top of the Week 4 power rankings
Step right up, step right up. Win a prize
Just by making it to the two-minute warning
with one timeout
Oh it is on! Time's yours fellas
Time, time, time-out.  Ah sh-
I won again Dad- I mean Coach
Step right up, and I'll guess your weight within five pounds
Hell no
Great hit, that's OK, great sack, great hit,
ow, that's OK though
For only four quarters, I'll predict your future
Ha ha ha ha ha
Ow my back, ow ow ow
What is your question?
Uh, when will Gronk die?
June 9th
Nice!